these are Royal Air Force and Royal Navy
helicopters aircraft like these have
been used in the past to evacuate
wounded troops in war zones now they're
teaming up with the NHS as flying
ambulances on the coronavirus frontline
it's a new mission that may need a new
approach if we've got a patient who is
suffering any sort of respiratory
distress then obviously we'll be advised
by the medical team but for instance we
may not climb to altitude in order to
make sure that they the oxygen levels
stay stay stable for the patients and
also we'll take advice from the medical
team on the speed that they want to
arrive at the next facility or weather
smoothness of flying it is a high
priority depending on the amount of care
that they're providing to the patients
at the time the military and the medics
are learning how to work together this
training session on Thursday was with an
ambulance team in Hampshire they're also
learning on the job as the need for the
support is now the aviation task force
is one of an unprecedented range of jobs
being carried out by the military in
this crisis some 23,000 service
personnel are earmarked for the covert
support force including around 3,000 who
are already deployed more than 12
military helicopters are on standby to
help and over 2300 defence vehicles are
set to be used as ambulances and to
deliver supplies as of now the Armed
Forces are responding to 85 requests for
help from civilian authorities including
in the construction of hospitals and of
testing centres
despite their contribution permission
like this to film the military has so
far been rare rarer still is the chance
to speak to those in charge
this clip of the officer commanding the
mission was posted by the Ministry of
Defense I'm not pretending we're just
taking this in our stride because this
is quite exceptional but the three
services have now turned to to deliver
everything that the government wants as
the covert crisis grows so too will the
military support air crews like these no
this is just the start of what set to be
and lengthy operation Deborah Haines Sky
News